في هذه القريه الواقعه في منطقه خرسون
المحرره ندوب واثار الحرب ظاهره في كل
مكان
بعض القرويين الذين عادوا الى منازلهم
اكتشفوا حجم التمر مثل غسيل الذي كان يعمل
مزارعا قبل الحرب
لا اعرف ماذا افعل
الى المنطقه بعد ان حرارتها القوه
الاوكرانيه علينا ان نبدا من جديد سنبذل
قصار جهدنا لاعاده بناء انفسنا اولا فنحن
مازلنا شباب لكن بالنسبه لمن ليس لديهم ما
ينقذون فالامر مختلف لكن الاصعب هو ان
تعيش دون ماء او تدفئه خاصه درجات الحراره
في فصل جديد
للطاقه في البلاد رغم ذلك لا ينوي في هذه
التوقف عند هذا الحد
حاليا للطا
دوله مجاوره نعم قمنا بذلك ولكن من الذي
بدا من الذي قصف جسر القرن
في الاسابيع الاخيره الملايين من
الاوكرانيين وجدوا انفسهم بدون كهرباء
وماء وتدفئه النظام الكهربائي في اوكرانيا
لا يزال ضحيه عجز كبير بعد ضربات الروسيه
الاخيره